title design is a motion design
principle that is in high demand as the
industry increasingly relies on digital
motion graphics designers who specialize
in title design are in a prime position
to take advantage of this growing trend
and i'm here to tell you that you've
come to the right place and beyond title
design you'll learn everything you need
to know to create a stunning title
sequence from start to finish over the
course of nine modules you'll cover
everything from developing a concept and
designing your titles to animating them
and adding the finishing touches whether
you're just starting out in motion
design or you've been looking to take
your skills to the next level beyond
title design is the perfect way to learn
from the best in the business and create
a title sequence that will wow audiences
around the world and the best part is
that you can get started right away so
if you're ready to learn everything you
need to know about title design click
the link below and enroll in beyond
title design now